تريد إسرائيل أن يموت هذا الرجل، ياها إيلا،
زعيم حماس في غزة في مواجهة
الشر، في
النهاية، هذا الرجل أمام أعيننا، كل شيء
مسيل للدموع، سأصل إليهم، لقد
أدين لأول مرة في عام 1988 بتهمة القتل
جنديين إسرائيليين وأربعة
فلسطينيين يشتبه في تعاونهم
مع
إسرائيل، وأمضى عقدين من الزمن في
سجن إسرائيلي يدرس عدوه،
مؤسس قوة الأمن الداخلي التابعة لحماس،
وكان يطارد المتعاونين المزعومين مع
زيل، وكان من بين
أكبر جوائز الحركة عندما شارك أكثر من ألف
فلسطيني  تم إطلاق سراح الأسرى في
عام 2011 مقابل جلعاد شاليط، وهو
جندي إسرائيلي احتجز كرهينة في غزة لمدة خمس
سنوات،
وقال إنه لا شك أن هذه
لحظة وطنية بامتياز،
وهي واحدة من النصب الإستراتيجية الكبيرة في
تاريخ
قضيتنا وسرعان ما أصبح رئيسًا  بعد
انتخابه لرئاسة الجناح العسكري لحماس في
غزة عام
2017، ألغى فعلياً
فرعها المدني الذي نبذته مصر بسبب
دعمه للإسلام السياسي، وقام بإصلاح
صداقاته مع القاهرة وبنى
علاقات إقليمية عززت
قوة حماس، وكانت بحاجة حقاً إلى
علاقات جيدة أيضاً مع أممنا.  دولة كيا العربية
التي تشترك أيضًا في الحدود العربية الوحيدة
مع قطاع غزة ومع إيران
أم التي يمكن أن تزود حماس بالدعم
العسكري واللوجستي إيران
صبت الدعم العسكري لحماس
تحت قيادته وكانت قطر
داعمًا رئيسيًا للمشاريع المدنية هو  وسرعان ما أصبح
في مرمى إسرائيل،
وحاول جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي قتله في مايو
2021، وبعد 10 أيام، عرض
استراتيجيته وقال إنه إذا لم
يتخذ العالم إجراءات لوقف ذلك، فهذا يعني أن إسرائيل
ستكون هناك حرب دينية في
المنطقة وهو  وسرعان ما ظهر في غزة
إلى جانب الزعيم المصري الذكي عباس
الجمل بالنسبة لنا. وتعتمد الولايات المتحدة الآن على
مصر وقطر كلاعبين رئيسيين لمحاولة
تأمين إطلاق سراح آمن
لأسرى حماس البالغ عددهم 200. ومن المرجح أن تكون نقطة الاتصال الرئيسية بينهما خطيئة
ما لم تفي إسرائيل بوعدها
بالقتل.  له سام كايلي
سي إن إن